on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored
England will defy FIFA to protest
against gay rights at the Qatar World
Cup or rather uh the way they're not
being tolerated should protesting
footballers boycott the tournament just
get on with playing football or is the
virtually signaling enough emergency
measures in the Bank of England the
warning from the IMF but the worst is
still to come is it now too late to fix
our economic Mass allows billionaire
John calwell but ecozealous blocked a
fire engine an ambulance another day of
Chaos in London is it enough that these
half wits are supposed to enjoys me live
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
and welcome to Facebook and our sense
and it's impossible to watch any sport
today without a social justice sermon of
some kind eat your peas be kind and then
we'll let you watch the game Premier
League footballers lineup with Ukrainian
Flags before tying up their rainbow
laces for gay rights probably while
already kneeling for black lives matter
Lewis Hamilton's rainbow helmet poked
out from an F1 car painted all in black
as a stand against discrimination the
NFL has racial Justice messaging on
helmets on referee's caps even on the
pitch itself at one point Arsenal and
Chelsea shirts were so congested with
supporting badges they literally ran out
of space they promised to wear a mental
health awareness patch but it wouldn't
fit around the NHS patch and the BLM
patch it's well it's exhausting isn't it
uh now let me be clear in all those
cases emphatically support the social
cause behind the gestures but these
choreographed exhibitions of let's be
honest virtue signaling have begun to
lose a lot of their meaning and rather
than winning over the fans it's
beginning to alienate them by well
winding them up
if a player wants to take a stand or a
knee or wear a badge that's of course
they're right but ramming it down the
throats a football fans just want to
watch football and don't really want to
be exposed to Too Much political
lecturing or hectoring I don't think
that's going to fly anymore the English
FA said today that Captain Harry Kane
will wear a one love Rainbow armband at
the World Cup in Qatar where being gay
is disgracefully illegal I've no doubt
Harry Kane means well he's a good a good
guy but to me it's a bit of a weak
gesture it's Max of tokenism it's not
going to change anything about qatar's
attitude to gay rights and if the
England team really truly has a serious
moral objection to This World Cup being
staged in Qatar perhaps they should
boycott the tournament that might
concentrate more minds and affect more
change but I suspect most England fans
would rather that the players just
focused on winning the matches and the
tournament and left the virtue signaling
at home will joining me now and Studios
broadcaster Adrian child it's a former
Vice chairman doesn't seem a good enough
title to me the former God of Arsenal
Football Club David D the man who
brought me more pleasure as a fan of
Arsenal than any other human being in
history uh it was also part of England's
bid to host the 2018 World Cup which of
course was lost to Russia
and the great football manager Harry
redknapp is at his home in Poole
probably heard that these two were here
and decided he wouldn't bother getting
the train up Harry great to see you
um so a stellar lineup it's a really
interesting uh debate this because and
Bollywood comes to your brilliant books
you guys so don't worry
um
agent it's a really interesting uh
debate or this it really cuts to sports
washing virtue signaling
how the line is drawn what is the LIE
should there be a line when you heard
that Harry Kane was going to wear this
one love badge promoting gay rights in
Qatar where it's illegal to be gay what
was your reaction as a football fan well
I suppose like you I'd feel well it
feels that strongly don't go on the
other hand if he is going to go at the
end of the day he is going to go and
play for England I'd rather he was
wearing that armband than not wearing it
which is just a which is just a long
difference
well here's my point once you once you
go down this road of signaling virtue
whatever The Virtue is that you care
about where do you stop and who do you
who do you not do it for in other words
once you start doing this as we've seen
before some clubs run out of space on
their shirts to promote their virtue and
I'm at some point I'm I support all
these causes I do you know I support
black lives matter I support the
campaign for gay rights to equality and
so on I said well all these things but
as a football fan I'm a little bit sick
and tired of it to be honest well I
think plainly if you're running out of
space on the shirt something's gone
wrong and if you support every cause to
some extent you support no causes at all
right in the end but I think there
should be allowed to support what
they're passionate what they're
passionate about and if Harry's doing
that then I would say good luck to in
terms of sport watching in terms of
where the tournament's being held yeah I
think that's kind of all over now after
not after Qatar which still seems
Bonkers to me on almost every level but
but Russia you know the idea go to
Russia and you know we'll you know we'll
bring them into the world family will
almost civilize them or something
everything's going to be better and we
go we have a fantastic tournament and
where's that goddess it happens it had a
certain element to it didn't it of you
know well Hitler ran the trains well you
know Putin put on a good tournament
actually none of that makes any
difference to what they're really about
so next time
next time the argument's made where he
needs to go to Country X because it will
be a force for good well it might be for
the duration of the tournament but it
can all go pear-shaped very quickly okay
Harry redknapp Harry Kane wants to wear
a one love badge on his arm as England
captain in Qatar or it's illegal to be
gay should he be doing that
I don't know whether a hairy one you
know is it Harry's Choice really or is
it the fa or whoever
you know saying this and Harry this will
be a great gesture I agree with Adrian
really I mean what harm does it do but
then again what good does it do probably
none
um you know but I don't know where you
go I'm with you I'll be honest peers the
way you introduced a show I think you
said it all for me I I just you know you
you summed it up perfectly it's it's all
gone crazy we're all getting you know at
times you you get I agree with
everything you know I'm I'm I you know I
I'm behind all the great causes but I
think it's going a bit too far now we're
just really it's non-stop non-stop you
know we do want to just get on with
things without having to keep worrying
about people wearing this doing that
doing that it's just for me it's uh it's
it's gone over the top a little bit now
David Dean first of all welcome you've
got a fantastic book calling the shots
and for people who don't know who you
are and I find it hard to believe nobody
knows who you are uh you ran Arsenal in
the what I call the the most glorious
period in our history three great titles
a bunch of fa cups silverware coming out
of our ears he brought us some Banger to
the club and for eight nine years the
best manager in the world as far as I
was concerned brought glorious football
to us and then you had to leave in
dramatic Southern circumstances forced
out in a boardroom uh bust up and it's
never really been the same since
although funnily enough I think they
must have heard you were coming on my
show because Arsenal finally begun to
play actually as well as they did when
you left the when you left the arena let
me ask you first of all how are you very
well thank you very much are you happy
to see our boys at top of the premium
yes indeed stop the race
[Laughter]
there's a wonderful uh new chart which
has gone up at Arsenal and it's a little
bit self-indulgent but if you can't be
self-indulgent on your own show well
when can you be as a massive Arsenal fan
for 52 years we finally have our own
song and it's written by a guy called
Louis Dunford the fans have adopted it
and just soak a little bit of this in
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's a North Londoner and the video that
goes with it is a wonderful little
snapshot of community life in North
London it really moved me actually and I
love the fact the fans have adopted it I
love the fat one with top of the league
it's all great at the moment but it also
reminds me and I think you is a West
Brom fan will certainly relate to this
you can't enjoy the good times in
football yeah without having gone
through unrelenting misery and pain
that's true we all have to suffer don't
we yeah
without despair there is no Health there
can't be and I think of all the joy I've
had as an Arsenal fan it is massively
enhanced by the misery I've had to
endure either the two go hand in hand I
think that's true but of course the pain
of losing weighs much heavier than the
joy of winning it does you know it lasts
longer does it you were involved over
very high levels uh with the Football
Association on on the international
stage as well when you were at Arsenal
when you look at this whole issue of
morality and Sport let's just call it
what it is whether it's the live golfers
a war with the PGA whether it's having a
World Cup and Qatar for agent summed it
up brilliantly about that look at what
happened with Russia we kind of allowed
them to hijack the game for a tournament
and now they're at war in Europe as a
sort of a return Act where is the line
morally for you with sport when you were
doing deals around the world and stuff
is there a line or is it all littered
with hypocrisy well I think part of the
problem is they suggest raised its head
really now 40 days before we're kicking
off the World Cup which is a shame Qatar
won the World Cup bid 12 years ago why
have a controversy now at this stage and
in the end it'll be left really to FIFA
to adjudicate and decide what should be
done and what shouldn't be done is it
smart of Harry Kane to to go ahead and
wear a badge which will clearly upset
local people in Qatar we can have our
own view about their rules about
homosexuality but it is their country
their culture well let me give you
something similar you may remember in
2017 England were playing Germany at
Wembley and we wanted to wear a poppy
because it was just before Armistice and
FIFA at the time didn't want us to do it
and I remember I was part of the fa
delegation but lobbied FIFA and in the
end they did agree for us to wear the
badge the poppy badge on the sleeve not
on the main shirt itself and these these
all things up for debate but of course
once they allow England to do something
what about the red there'll be other
people lobbying you know it'll be
Ukraine or be Croatia or be Palestine or
somebody else would come on right and
say we want to do something similar is
it easier to Simply keep it out of sport
but at the same time there is there has
to be a campaign quite rightly so
against discrimination right and I can
understand the fa quite rightly standing
up and Harry Kane as the captain being
an iconic figure for that campaign I
mean hurricanes indecent guy I mean uh
Harry redknapp you know Harry Kane he's
a he's a top bloke I really like him
personally he may well not have made
this decision
um I I just wonder you know we discussed
this earlier but I just wonder whether
it's just easier for sport to stay out
of these things that once you go down
this road where does it stop and how
much effect does it really have you've
already seen a lot of teams wanting to
stop taking the knee actually led by
their black players saying it's not
enough it's fine to do this but what's
it actually achieving in the cause of
racial equality or or stopping racial
Injustice
but you know the difficult thing appears
when you're in a team are you going to
be the one that stands up and say listen
I don't I don't want to do this now and
fill up with it you know we've made this
stand we've done what we had to do you
know when everybody's doing it are you
going to be the one that is going to get
slaughtered for not doing it what if two
or three might not agree with it and
think well you know we've made that
we've done we've made our point so we're
you know it may not necessarily be uh
every you know it's a team and now you
have to follow each other it might not
even be their views in lots of cases
that they should be still be doing
whatever whether it's taking a knee or
whether it's wearing armbands or
whatever but they're they're probably
it's very difficult to come out and be
the you know the couple that even though
you you agree with that you know it's
completely wrong there's no place for
racism there's no place for you know it
but you've got to be the one that comes
out and says no the two or three that
you know said look I'm not going to do
it anymore it's very very hard decision
to make and you know you know you you
say one word out of placement these days
you'll do one thing slightly wrong that
people with the establishment they don't
agree with and you really are in trouble
yeah I completely agree
um talking of people really being in
trouble the good Drinker Adrian Charles
how I learned to love drinking less you
went now you may not like us for doing
this but we read the book and our team
managed to assemble what you were
drinking in an average week at the
height of your drinking and and this
year I think we've got a shot of it all
here I think so this is a hundred units
10 bottles of wine
50 pints of beer that's what it was
equivalent to that was your weekly
intake week after week month after month
year after you a how are you still
standing let alone being one of the top
television Personalities in the country
and secondly what made you stop well
a couple of things in terms of the
quantity the reason I could do it is
that it was my Misfortune then I was I
was good at it I was just good I didn't
I never got drunk I wasn't you know I
wasn't out particularly late it was just
constantly topping up it wasn't
obviously outwardly affecting my health
and actually then as part of the program
I had a liver scan and there was a bit
of a bit of a bit of damage there and I
just thought hang on can I address this
or do I have to just stop drinking and
then I thought well now let me try and
see if I can drink less and I mean the
realization I got very simply was that
if you lined up all the drinks I drunk
in my life it'd be about four miles long
or three miles long yeah I think so I
did on the back of an envelope now I
mean that's a lot of poison to put
through your body and I just the real
tragedy for me is if I look at how many
how many of those drinks are really
wanted or needed or enjoyed and it's
much less than half most of the time
it's just drinking for the sake of
drinking because it was kind of what you
did or you're in the pub at nine o'clock
and it doesn't shut till 11. most people
you get who get to that stage of
drinking they either give up completely
or they get worse sadly and a lot of
people die from alcoholism how are you
able to I guess have the self-discipline
and control to just reduce it massively
to a level where you can still enjoy a
drink but you don't feel that need to to
drink as much I think for once I just
did a lot of thinking about it and the
more people I talked about it the more
experts in the field the more I realized
you know they you know flip people sense
things to me like one guy West bromfan
actually said it's important we take
alcohol off its undeserved pedestal in
our lives it's not the be all an end-all
it's a useful thing but you know your
life mustn't your life absolutely
mustn't revolve around it and also
realizing that the only drink that has
an impact is the first one it achieves a
change of state and that's lovely
and then maybe the second one but each
subsequent drink is just a vain attempt
to recreate here I mean just drink the
fourth class of a shuttle at all 61. I
mean I mean David you would know you've
probably drunk I prefer the 62 myself
but never more than four well that
reveals you I'm afraid you're shameful
ignorance yeah it's a great bulldoze um
David you also have a terrific book and
by the way the good drink is a
fascinating read uh anyone who's who
thinks they might have an issue a drink
it's a really good one because you end
up still drinking you just don't drink
yourself in an early grade David your
book obviously from my point of view as
a great fan of Arsenal found it riveting
I'm more interested about the fact that
it all ended so acrimoniously not just
for you but also then for arson Wenger
he's great manager I'm not going to
divorce myself from any blame for
forcing him out the NFL he went on way
too long I'm honest uh but for eight
nine years he was an absolute Legend
he's never been back to Arsenal since
2018 since he left left the club there's
a statue waiting to be unveiled and
there's been a big piece in the papers
today that it's time that he made his
piece that the new manager Michael
arteter has said please come back we
want you to be part of it the fans want
him to come back what do you think one
of his best friends what do you feel
about it yeah well firstly I think it's
right that he should be acknowledged for
what he did 22 years get into the
Champions League 20 successive times I
wish a [ __ ] to do that again so it
should be recognized and I hope that
that he will realize that at some stage
to come back and unveil a statue he
deserves one for sure yeah because he's
brought as you quite really said the
opening part of your program he gave us
the best time ever in Arsenal's history
yeah and I was delighted to be part of
that yeah well you brought him there
well thank you for saying that yeah did
he go on too long uh I know you've said
that before
I I feel it it's a great shame he was
not embraced even if he was not going to
be a tracksuit manager or coach anymore
he should with his knowledge he should
have still been within the organization
somewhere meanwhile he's not good enough
for Arsenal but he is good enough to be
Global head of football development for
the world for FIFA so you're both going
to be in Qatar for the world who's going
to be in Qatar for that and I'm actually
going to be in Qatar good and I've been
doing my show from the World Cup for a
week in the Philippines and you will
enjoy is it Madness to think that the
three of us could sit around why not and
I tell you what now this is a message to
all your viewers Qatar will be a huge
success it's a very welcoming place I've
been there many times in fact last time
I was there was in November of the Arab
cup which was it was a great experience
had a winning football alive no one
knows better than you because he
honestly you did an amazing thank you
everything you did for [ __ ] we all
greatly appreciate it Adrian Giles for
everything you've done for West Brom I
love a good a lot of good it's done and
Harry redknapp who uh probably I think
you'd agree Harry your greatest
achievement in World football was
winning soccer Aid with me as the
co-manager
absolutely yeah that was that was a
great couple of days peers I must be
truthful but I agree with everything
that David says about arsene Wenger you
know
amazing manager amazing football man
really I'd love to see him go back there
and unveiled that statue because he
really deserves it you know what I would
I would say use that fantastic brain
yeah I listen I was one of his biggest
fans and then one of his most vociferous
critics I think I would stand by the
criticism but he went on too long but he
was a complete legend of the club and he
absolutely deserves a statue he deserves
to be back there so I hope he does go
back there gentlemen I could talk about
this all night unfortunately the viewers
wouldn't want me to but I could uh David
great to see you Adrian good to see you
best of luck with the books you guys and
Harry always great to have you on the
show thank you very much
good to see you pierce
we'll still become billionaire John
Caldwell and why he's turning off his
heating to help beat Vladimir Putin and
whether he regrets backing Liz trust to
run the country
and I regret to say that added again to
stop oil protesters blocking emergency
vehicles in the Streets of London this
afternoon we've got one of them in the
studio with me I suspect it's going to
be a little Lively that discussion
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to pierce organizations the
bank of England today made another
emergency intervention into the British
economy it's the third time it's been
forced to access the kilometers mini
budget the IMF meanwhile said the worst
is yet to come with the global economy
one of the Britain faces High inflation
for longer than similar economies
bachelor's trust needs a word with my
next guest joining me is the billionaire
entrepreneur John Caldwell alongside
author and journalist Jenny Cleveland
and talk TV through the letter to Kate
McCann welcome to all your Stellar
battle ever there was one John cooler
great to see you
um as one of the richest most successful
people in the country what on Earth do
you make of this Basket Case of a few
weeks we've had with the economy well
it's not in just a few weeks it's a few
years unfortunately because all the
wrong things were done right at the
start of the pandemic and there should
have been a lot a lot of different
actions taken by Rishi sunat first of
all so all of this crisis started way
back then and of course the pandemic was
a huge challenge to overcome but there
was lots of ways of managing it more
shrewdly than we did and those mistakes
have now added to the inflation which is
of course also caused by the Ukraine
situation and the hyperinflation of
energy prices so the whole lot has come
to together is a storm which has not
been settled down by Liz trust well she
called she's bought a lot of fuel onto
the fire absolutely with this mini
budget I mean many economists I talk to
you think she's talking complete
nonsense and quasi-quarting that this
idea that you can get growth growth
growth by unleashing all these massive
tax cuts without actually any way of
funding them yeah they think is a
complete disaster I mean I agree with
your you agree no I I agree with that
that's not to say I've ever been against
borrowing more money but I wanted to
borrow more money to invest in the
economy to grow GDP if you only borrow
the money to put into people's pockets
and rely on that feeding through and
creating growth it's not going to work
because all it'll do is create inflation
and of course that's where we are now
we're in a desperate situation right
okay I mean I watched uh quasi-quarters
today in Parliament I thought he was
pretty hopeless to be honest with you
every time he veered off his tight
script he just sounded less and less
confident and the problem is it's not
about whether he's confident it's about
other people in the city's confidence in
him and at the moment there isn't any in
fact they think things are going to get
a lot worse very quickly and the what
he's managed to do is make things
immeasurably more difficult for this
country to get out of soaring inflation
yeah and I think look at what's had to
happen he's had to bring forward his
medium-term fiscal report to the end of
the month to Halloween and at that point
Halloween Horror well the Halloween
budget I mean you couldn't really have
have chosen a worse date for it in
theory but what that has to do is a huge
amount of work he has to reassure the
markets that he has this covered and to
do that he says he's going to give
long-term plans on things like planning
infrastructure investment there are
eight of these growth plans but I was
speaking to number 10 yesterday and they
say well don't expect to see all of
those at the end of the month that's a
huge problem because if we can't see
what his plan is and how he's going to
reassure the markets then they know
won't necessarily be reassured and I
think his performance in the comments
today is worth highlighting because
actually quasi-quartang really struggled
against his own side his own MPS you
know chair of the treasury select
committee former Chief whip these are
not Rebels these are people who are
inside the camp who are saying we're not
comfortable we're not happy you need to
reach out and study the ship and if you
don't then you'll have some real
problems what will the trigger point be
for a genuine Rebellion against Liz
trust and quasi quote well I think
actually what's happening tonight is
quite problematic because Andrew Bailey
has made comments saying that what the
bank of England is doing will definitely
end on Friday and that's caused a real
problem for the pound already now that's
happening as we speak right now that
shows you how jittery markets are what
the confidence is like everyone in
Parliament has eyes on that they are all
concerned about the long-term damage
that's being done here because when we
talk about guilts what we're talking
about is the cost of government
borrowing how much it costs all of us to
borrow the money that they're proposing
to grow the economy now the IMF today
has said well yes the UK's economy will
grow potentially more than we expected
but so will inflation it'll be running
really high and that's a problem for all
and generally this is a problem isn't it
is you can talk a good game on this
stuff it looks to me like they play
casino politics they've rolled the dice
all on red it's all coming up blank and
I don't think they have the experience
or the know-how to Now guide themselves
out of this floundering ship on the Rock
and I think it's more than that I think
we have reached this critical point
where trust is lost any faith that we
might have in this very young government
is gone and markets don't have faith
voters don't have faith I don't think
they can ever regain the confidence of
markets and and voters they had an
opportunity there was a window uh after
the mini budget where they could have
said the right things they could have
reassured people they have floundered uh
you know obviously these measures the
bank of England's measures coming to an
end on the 14th of October has meant
that already the prices of bonds is
going up because people don't trust the
government to be able to you know keep
things on and even John I don't care if
they're tall worries if they're labor if
they're a lib Dem labor pain I don't
care actually what I care about is their
ability to navigate us through
incredibly difficult times and what I
really object to is it seems to have
been list trust and quasi-classic almost
on their own without any conversation
with their cabinet even about these key
factors of the mini budget which has now
turned disastrously wrong I didn't vote
for these two to do this nobody did yeah
um they don't have a mandate to behave
in the way they're behaving no it's it's
extremely frustrating but I'm frustrated
more in the long term because because I
put in a plan to the government in March
2020 when I saw exactly what was going
to happen as a result of the pandemic I
first of all said nobody should be
substantially worse off Rishi got that
wrong and made people substantially
better off in in a large set of people
and then made other people a lot worse
off so you got all that wrong but I also
put in what I call Caldwell pandemic
recovery which was a method apology of
making Britain boom in the long term and
the central piece of that was to set up
an Enterprise Zone for inward investment
from all the countries and the world on
environmental technology and grow what I
call the Silicon Valley of the
environment in the UK and that would
have provided a long-term income stream
in in a really desperately needed sector
what is the environment one of the
things the markets hate is
unpredictability obviously a massive
unpredictable thing is the war in
Ukraine and you have a personal interest
in this you've actually taken in a
Ukrainian family first of all what made
you do that and what's it been like
having this family live with you well I
I I I I thought it was absolutely
horrendous when Putin
invaded it and I think NATO and NATO
incidentally made a massive mistake
there we should have sent troops in
protected the Ukraine borders and then
leave it to Putin if he wanted to create
a world or not be now on the defensive
all the time and let in innocent Ukraine
people get slaughtered so I think that
was a colossal mistake in all of this
um I wanted to help out as much as I
possibly can so right at the beginning I
went on uh social media and looked for a
Ukraine family uh and I got a mother and
son who were desperate there were there
were desperately emotionally uh damaged
and just wanted safety and the husband
the father's on the front line I think
yeah and of course they are there living
a life
a very pleasant life with me when
everything's provided and they've got
lovely grounds a lovely life but they've
got this compelling cloud of what's
Happening back home what's happening to
a husband what's happening to all the
relatives and friends and what's
happening to a Homeland and and she
bursts into tears quite regularly as
you'd naturally expect because she
doesn't she doesn't know none of us know
so I mean it's a tragic situation well
good for you for doing that
um one thing you said is that as part of
the battle over energy for example the
the British public should rally now and
start to conserve individual quantities
of energy why do you feel that's
important well that's a minor step and
it's been blown slightly out of
proportion but I still think that is a
really good thing to do because we've
got very high energy prices when I was a
kid like a lot of people of my age we
lived in housed the freezing cold no
heating hardly at all and so on I'm not
suggesting we go back to that but what
we can all do is reduce our energy
consumption which is great for the
environment and will reduce how are you
doing I mean obviously you're a very
wealthy guy you've got a lot of
electricity what are you doing well I
pre I preach to people that they should
do this and take measures to cut energy
consumption so I'm doing it myself and
I've switched my heating off at home I
just have my kitchen wall my bedroom
when it gets to freezing temperatures
put a little bit of heat in the bedroom
but I'm I'm practicing what I preach
because I don't want to be hypocritical
about it so even though financially it
makes no difference to me whatsoever I
just think I do my bit and leave from
the funds that I always have done Jenny
I think it's a fantastic idea and what
surprises me is that uh the uh the
government is so uh reluctant because
they don't want to be appear appeared to
be a kind of Nanny state that they don't
want to give people any kind of tips at
all about how they might do this even
obviously we all know you can turn your
heating off and put a jumper on but what
about things to do with insulation or
turning your boiler down the fact that I
would save energy by turning off the
lights and Liz truss and quasi-quarters
offices because it seems to me the more
light they have the more cataclysmically
bad work they're doing I think they care
very much about how they are seen of
what they stand for rather than doing
what's best for the country and these
are very simple things that they could
do and it's great that John is here
telling us what he's doing but why
aren't we being given more more advice
elsewhere I agree some sad news just
come coming in Dame Angela Lansbury from
Murder She Wrote has died at the age of
think of 96 one of the great actresses
of her generation uh absolutely beloved
figure so very sad news they're just
coming in uh she'll be a lot of tributes
there's a statement here uh of called
Murder She Wrote Beauty and the Beast so
many films and television projects the
statement from the family to the
children of Dame Angela Lansbury are sad
to announce that their mother died
peacefully in her super home in Los
Angeles at 1 30 a.m today Tuesday
October the 11th there's five days shy
of her 97th birthday what an amazing
career and an amazing life and this of
course probably the music should be most
associated with for Murder She Wrote
we'll see you off the bike
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
looks really bad earlier next year why
would they keep it well because I think
the problem they've got politically is
that the country won't suffer another
leadership election and the party is not
coalescing around one leader in a
situation where you really wanted rid of
Liz truss if there was one person who
came through the middle and everyone
could agree there didn't need to be a
contest then maybe but that person
doesn't exist so you've got a party
where there are lots of frustrated MPS
we've actually never really pathetic is
that there's nobody
and when I say you know the mood amongst
those MPS a lot of them are new MPS they
feel like they've been hard done by they
feel like we've never had a great you
know run of it in Parliament it's always
been very difficult we've had brexit
we've had covered we've never really
been as part of the United party and
then you've got the older hands who say
well this is more 92 than 97 yes we'll
get a drubbing but we'll probably still
win but that's not great either because
it leaves I mean the worst thing I've
read this week is that Boris Johnson
doesn't wish to comment on rumors you
may come back I mean he's only just they
just got rid of him
then you want him back I don't want
Boris Johnson back
around the head with a great
Sledgehammer I just wants the attention
of being he wants the attention of being
a bit intrigued probably she's making
him look good isn't she well I mean
there were a lot there's a lot of buyers
the most going on is that what Boris was
a clown and a illegal party and all the
rest of it but at least he wasn't Liz
trust back in the day in the kind of
depths of the summer when uh he came out
in support of Liz Trussell rather there
was a sense that he was supporting Liz
trust I think it was Dominic Cummings
who said that who said that he thought
that it was because she was going to
make such a mess out of it they would
give him the opportunity to go back in
So if you're a conspiracy theorist you
might believe that I don't know I just I
think well his hero is Winston Churchill
and that's the problem because
driven out by an ungrateful public and
then he roared back years later to put
things back on track uh John Galway
Switching gears a bit King Charles III
the coronation will be on Saturday May
the 6th it's around the bank holiday
there
um there's a lot of reports that they
may try and slim it down but rather than
the big four-hour coronation that we saw
for the queen his mother the for him and
his own Queen Camilla it may be a
shortened version maybe an hour or so
and less Pomp and pageantry I've got to
say I'm in two minds about this I
understand the Optics in the middle of a
cost of living crisis but I also looked
to what happened at the Queen's funeral
and thought my God we showed the world
what we can do when we put on this kind
of thing and that was a very sad
occasion now we have a chance for a
glorious celebration of our new monarch
is it right to skimp I mean you you live
like a king yourself
I've been to your place but
um should we just go for it and say you
know what actually this is what we do
better than anybody else we should
because the Pomp and ceremony is
something that we do brilliantly well it
creates a lot of revenue for Britain
through tourism uh the monarchy have
been the key people in the monarchy have
been exceptionally good the queen is
probably the greatest not probably is
the greatest Monet that's ever lived and
probably ever will live and I think King
Charles has done a great job in lots of
areas of the environment and
architecture and so on and I think
you'll be a pretty good King as well and
I think we should celebrate that and
show the world that we can celebrate it
in spite of the rather difficult
circumstances we're in at the moment
this is what I think Jenny I presume you
think the complete opposite day well I
don't think I think there's a delicate
Balancing Act I think we live now in a
digital age where people's attention
spans are a lot shorter I think four
hours might be a bit much you can make
one hour very Sensational I also think
you know the coronation it's not a
reality TV show you know it's a
coronation the staying power for it
believe me but also I mean the the
carriage the special coronation
carriages like a gold carriage and you
have to imagine at a time when a lot of
people are you know have no savings
anymore
I didn't agree with the Royal yacht
Britannia being taken away I don't agree
with all these things being taken away I
don't agree with our prime minister
flying a you know easy jet whatever it
was with David Cameron did it I think if
you're going to have leaders and head to
State and monarchs then they've got to
have all the trinkets I think King
Charles has done a very good job so far
at combining being Regal with being
humble and his first big speech that he
gave there was humility in it he
accepted uh you know the enormity of the
office didn't feel didn't come across as
feeling entitled to it I think he's been
very well advised they'll find a balance
where it doesn't look like a ridiculous
splash of cash I was in America last
week everyone wanted to talk about the
Queen's funeral and how you know how
fantastic it was I I anchored it for Fox
and they would just rave
this extraordinary woman and be the
amazing Pomp and pageantry and
everything else John quick plug for your
book title
love paying money which has brought you
more pleasure
I think I'm a masochist so it's a
problem
but the pain and the love go together
yeah but I wanted because you you
actually I I think you're an absolutely
brilliant example of a self-made success
story in this country we should be very
proud to have you and I'm looking
forward to reading it I think you always
be common sense which is a massively
overlooked virtue final question uh for
UK before we let you go about Madonna
but dollar has come out with a clip of
herself wearing a pair of hot pink
panties throwing them into a trash can
and saying if I miss I'm gay
it's now 1.3 million views have we got
this
so my big question for you came again is
is she now identifying as gay or is she
as Isis bait continuing to identify as
the most gruesome attention seeker in
the history of world celebrity I think a
lot of people are still very confused
about what that video was aiming at uh
you know I think that's that there's
definitely a question there she's
provocative that's what she does what
she's always done I think she's well you
don't have to necessarily like it or
agree with it but that's what I mean
what you're talking about I don't even
want her to see it but you're talking
about it because she's provocative I
know I'm playing into her trap which is
she wants attention and I'm giving it to
her but honestly utterly ridiculous she
I'm afraid is my douche of the day
if you wanted to do that for ages I
can't think of a more deserting
recipient uh thank you to my my terrific
panel John best of luck with the book
great to see you please come back Andrew
okay what a pleasure to see you so early
in the evening in the studio I know with
all our new changes great to have you
here thank you and Jenny you're staying
with me to shout out oil protesters all
support them what's out we're Serge
you're on here coming next Eco zealots
block of fire engine and an ambulance
another day of protests in London one of
the Ring leaders of these oil protesters
joins me live
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Start Spreading the News Pierce is
taking the show to New York City with
big guests in the Big Apple heavyweight
champion Mike Tyson the most
controversial man in American News
Tucker Carson the man who tried to kill
the President John Hinckley Jr and many
more join Piers Morgan uncensored in New
York City
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
sounds very exciting doesn't it uh
looking forward to that it's going to be
a big week from the Big Apple next week
so stick with us all next week as I'm
sure you do every night
um but welcome back for now to
protesters from just stop oil who spent
11 days demonstrating in London blocking
roads throwing painted shops and
restaurants today a fire engine and an
ambulance were briefly caught up in
their blockade prompting the British
government to save this kind of protest
isn't acceptable what Jenny Cleveland's
still with me I'm joined by the talk to
the contributor Richard ties and from
just stop oil a James key Mrs ski
welcome thank you very much for coming
in appreciate it at what point when
you're blocking fire engines and
ambulances are you concerned about lives
being cost lost by what you're doing
well the whole reason we're doing this
is because we're concerned about the
lives you get the irony that if you're
actually stopping ambulances and fire
engines is going to save people's lives
they may actually die because of your
protest well actually we have a blue
light policy we're let through every
emergency vehicle you didn't and if you
actually care to run the whole footage
there you'd see that that ambulance is
advised by one of our people uh to avoid
the roadblock and the the first why did
you do the sensible thing or just get
out of the way you have no right yeah
absolutely no right to obstruct other
people's daily lives you have the right
to protest on the side of the street you
are unlawfully in the middle of the
street it's utterly outrageous it's
selfish and you are putting people's
lives at risk I I appreciate your
frustration and I understand that I
empathize with that but look we are
demanding that the the government hold
any new licensing and consent for any
fossil fuel exploration in the UK now
you know that that needs to happen
it does need to happen
we need to ensure millions of people
living on this planet the United Nations
and the International Community
on their lives because of cheap energy
from fossil fuels you can't get cheaper
than free all right okay Renewables are
nine times cheaper than faster
spend 15 billion subsidizing Renewables
we spend 236 million pounds a week
sorry James what you're saying is alive
just to bring you back it's actually my
show and I'm doing the interview
although happily talk to you well John
didn't exercise and by the way he's not
frustrated he's Furious right my
question remains though with you where
is your moral line with this you say you
want to save lives and yet your actions
are bordering on potentially costing
lives you cannot get in the way of
Emergency Services in the way that
you're doing and if you do want to
explain the moral difference between
what you're doing and what you complain
everyone's doing about the planet
well I mean let's look if we want to
talk about disruption I mean earlier
the fire brigade the lunar fire brigade
had their busiest day since the blitz
okay 60 UK families lost their houses
and wildfires why are we not talking
about the business why are we
concentrating on such a small bit of
Destruction
is nothing in comparison to what's
coming here and you know it you know it
you think it's small I say to you you
have no idea the damage you're doing
when you get in the way of Emergency
Services
why are the lives of the people who
you're putting at risk by stopping those
fire engines why are you manipulating
your audience
finish my question why are the lives of
the people who whose lives may be
affected by your actions today why are
they less important to you than the
lives that you say will be cost by not
taking climate change more seriously I
value everyone's life
absolutely stop lying in front of
emergency
I for the record I agree with you I
think it's ridiculous it's down to
nurses doctors bartenders and whatnot to
be going out in the street and demanding
what the government should just be doing
anyway right this is this is
it wouldn't work wait wait wait okay
yeah I think and and I don't want to
speak for you James I think a lot of
these campaigns have to do with it's a
numbers game but there may be a small
number of people inconvenienced uh today
but they are looking at an existential
threat way into the future which will
involved many many right now many many
more people and the fact is this protest
is incredibly effective because here we
are we're talking about it
[Music]
caring passionately about causes right
I'm not saying I'm against your cause
I'm really getting against your
methodology doesn't it I don't think it
does open a history books it doesn't
work highly disruptive Civil Rights
Movement highly disruptive gay rights
highly disruptive you know it works
you're a journalist you've done your
research you know this let me finish we
wouldn't be on here
I don't think it works when you're lying
in front of Emergency Services I don't I
don't you will lose the British public
and my concern for you guys you keep
thank you any disruption is valid and
any disruption works and I'm saying to
you yes you're on this show but you're
on this show because people are
absolutely Furious yeah you got in the
way of ambulances and fire engines and I
say you can do both gun you you can make
vociferous protests but you don't have
to get in the way of things that are
saving people's lives why don't you tell
your audience about the the actual
disruption that's coming down the line
why don't you bring qualified climate
scientists on here to explain what
civilizational collapse looks like all
right we've lost a third of our wheat
yields this year we're projected to lose
50 of our potato Harvest if it's this
bad in 2022 how bad is it going to be in
2050 you know we have food shortages
that leads to
civilization collapse I'm sorry I'm
sorry
you're objectively wrong you are lying
we yielded on a third
degree in this country I didn't have to
go abroad it hit 40. you deranged are
you hit 40 degrees why do you want to
protest because in front of because we
have
the dogmatic nature as I have learned
myself screaming at the other side
rarely has the effect you think it does
it makes you feel better and I've done
it with you know people on various
debates it never actually works you
don't change anyone's Mind by screaming
but I think future Generations will
probably look back in shock and horror
at our ability to turn away from
something I don't necessarily think that
you will be winning over a lot of people
that don't already agree with your cause
with this you will be getting your
message
they'll hate us but they'll be what
we're doing
issue is important right which one as
well final question though are you going
to continue
stopping Emergency Services going about
they will continue until the government
makes a meaningful declaration
we've got to leave her there
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]